team black waiting on me one all right
my opponent was quickly typing at me
let's go with d5 let's go with d5 and
I'm gonna go with this I don't notice
chase this night away if the night plays
here when I was planning on doing Bishop
f5 and then challenging it right away
with 97 but I don't have to worry about
that which I just played 97 right now no
no no no no no this is where he's most
likely going to go I'm going with the
I'm retaining flexibility with my night
or with with that last move I was retain
flexibility my night my Queen night
might want to go to one of these two if
he if my Knights gonna go here I want to
have my pawn up first but let's reserve
this so with that last move having both
d4 and F for in this square is a whole I
would love to have these guys off the
board and then eventually have a knight
just right here and I think that that
could very easily lead to some trouble
I'm choosing this square instead of this
one because I might want to eventually
capture the night for when it plays to
this square and when that happens I
don't want to end up in a fork
so let me castle in fact if there's a
chap is challenged I think I'm going to
not capture the knight but rather play
here and be perfectly content with
double deaf pawns because it reinforces
my grip over efore and you know what
maybe I want to voluntarily play here no
no no I could just do this let me put
pressure on the center and get my seat
pot involved and if it's supported I'm
gonna throw another another piece on it
knight c6 another reason to have delayed
that Queen Knights development in the
end he does it classically developed in
another way to view it is if I if I
voluntarily played to this square I
wouldn't be threatening anything
and there there is sometimes the
potential for white to just let this
tension sit between the LightSquared
bishop s-- and in the event I capture
you capture with the pun and that would
fill that would repair the hole on e4
and also have there be some quick play
for white on that newly half-opened C
file so this is one that I'm considering
right now that the night is unpinned and
let's let's let's go with that
I can pre move that one there's not
going to be anything better
you get three I get three
I'm looking to eventually end up in a
position where I have a good night
versus my opponents bad bishop or a good
bishop versus a bad bishop or maybe a
better way to summarize it is I want to
end up in a position where this dark
square bishop stays on the board I don't
want him to exchange himself off for my
dark square bishop or my knights um so
what to do I could capture this Knight
right now this this is just barely being
held together by white they're in a
position where they're knighted they're
pieces are having to defend pieces so I
could capture this guy I don't want to
do that though
hmm I don't let me capture that bishop
force that night to retreat and I think
I just want to jump into this square
right now no no I don't want to do that
what do I want to do hmm I want to
release the tension if I capture it
captures like this then I can't make use
of that e4 square maybe that wasn't a so
great a decision to take the bishop
maybe I should have played 94 oh well
maybe just be six I want to keep this
tension and go with the b6 my knight is
no bit loose 2:28 about a minute
advantage forgive the sniffles for
something I don't know what it is this
soon as I begin live streaming I begin
the sniffle that's a fun one isn't it
yeah [ __ ] a fun little detail a fun
little detail my night is hit and I
don't want to take it so let's play here
all right defend the night and still
keep a close eye on this square I'm
intending just throwing my knight in the
center
efore okay I don't have anything more to
add that happens sometimes watch out for
those stream sniffles some people are
sitting in the chairs and the very
common a sniffle gambit just throw a
gambit after every word that's all you
have to do okay so if a four is going to
be played I believe I just take first
okay so this is probably a and I'm not
so sure what to do type of move so I
think I just sync this name or right in
there let's go for it
do I have any choice after Knight takes
tonight I guess I could first consider
Knight takes Knight but I don't want to
do that I don't want to do that you
notice I'm reluctant to be taking this
night because of the capturing towards
the center and then this rook has some
play I don't think that that was a good
decision to go forward with so I think
my queen is in a very good spot and this
this is the one piece that white is
still needing to get working I could
capture but I'm not going to with this
move I'm cementing this this pawn and if
after this capture well let's get this
rook working that maybe I want to get
this rook on the c8 square so that's why
I was going with the King rook to D the
a repent C and if this Queen comes over
in this direction I don't think I have
much fear my my bishop works perfectly
with my pawns these guys are out to
watch over light my bishop is around to
watch over dark and let's get this rook
working I'm okay with capture like this
now this pawn is going to be passed if
we do have that capture should I be
afraid
I don't think so I don't think these
pawns can get rolling
this is not so easy to break down if
this pound isn't around whoa whoa whoa
whoa hang on my first thought is
light-square weaknesses with that move
now I could take and after the recapture
I can I think just sit on these light
squares and I think that's going to be a
great inconvenience for white I think my
queen will be very well placed on this
square let me do that my queen is going
to be hit very shortly my question is B
5 or a 4 I think if the computer is
playing they go here because they like
they like material and so do I I'm not
gonna lie I'm not gonna lie but maybe
I'm gonna lie I like this better
I like this one better I like observing
the d3 square I'm coordinated I have
some communication with my pawn and
queen on d3
I am I have some pressure on b4 as well
which is being supported and I believe
sitting on this d3 Square it's just a
very very active square very active I
could think about B 5 and then pivoting
on c4 in the event the rook is captured
I have a I could recapture the pun and
have a connected past Potter I'm also
hitting a 3 and now that's having to be
defended and now here comes the that
follow-up position that you really want
to get once the rook is on an open file
you want to have it functioning
laterally and that's exactly what's
happening and now this is going to be
game over because of a skewer I had a
close eye on h4 and now this is tough so
the main thing as soon as that earliest
point when d4 was played my attention
was really focused on this guy the bad
bishop the bishop on d2 was difficult to
get him working and he turned out to
kind of be a tall pond
good game my opponent is saying good
game thank you thank you as well let's
go back quickly and flip the board and
check to see how things were from your
perspective so one thing here is well I
would be very very cautious of doing
this it's not in any way losing but just
of course recognize the weaknesses that
you leave behind the e4 square in
particular in addition to that what else
okay you're just this is a still very
solid set up some type of a stone wall
set up light square bishop Saar
challenged and okay
I think the knight move is fine you
recapture and now when you throw the
knight back there I think it's fine to
let him sit this is the one position
that I was kind of like I think I said
it I was saying this is maybe and I'm
not so sure what to do type of move I
think well what else can you be doing
maybe that's okay maybe that's still
okay but when I throw my knight in here
I don't think you should be giving up
your biggest asset I think your biggest
asset is keeping this Knight around on
that be 5 square excuse me yeah I think
you should stick around on e5 maybe h3
you could do without how else can we
maybe be looking at this position I
think I think it was maybe too easy for
black to equalize and that might be
maybe there's something more that it
could be trying to get out of the
opening but I'm kind of like that even
as white I'm okay to allow black get
into an equal position I tried and from
there I'll try to outplay come middle
game or endgame especially in blitz but
anyhow I think this is this is a trump
this is a good thing for you so keep him
sitting I'm not really that's that's why
that's why I played Queen c7 that's why
I'm not taking the night I think
would be beneficial for you for white if
I take and you're capturing like this
opening up the file for the rook so I
keep him sitting at that point made me
do something else maybe it may be
getting the Queen doing something else
not so sure the Queen move either maybe
the Queen is still good on this diagonal
maybe throw a question of the bishop and
then jump into this square and then get
your Queen to f3 and then maybe maybe
have ideas even of playing something
like g4 g5 but everything kind of comes
back to that dark square Bishop I kind
of worry when I see this guy behind this
dark square upon chain if he doesn't get
working it's going to be quite
problematic and in this game it turned
out to be problematic so one last thing
regarding the pawn moves this is I
believe fine your knight pawn attacking
my bishop on b4 I'm pretty sure is just
a mistake because your light squares are
significantly compromised what you could
maybe be trying instead is something
like B 3 and C 4 trying to get two pawns
on this fourth rank but playing b4 gives
me a free inroads by way of the light
squares and there's nothing you could do
about it so you could definitely do
without the b4 move but maybe it's
already busted before that that's just
going to win material now after Bishop
h4 okay good game again Appleman